hello Steve Kaufman here today I'm going
to talk about something that relates to
language and has to do with freedom of
speech and I'm calling it dialoging
because I had the experience about a
year ago of attending this conference or
discussion they hear it in Vancouver put
on by one of the local universities and
it was about dialoguing and there may be
100 people in the room I have is when
were students and before we began our
deliberations we were lectured by one of
the students on how we should conduct
our discussions that it was important to
use a technique of dialoguing and they
came the students were putting on this
this seminar were in a program at simon
fraser university called dialoguing
where you learn how to talk to people in
such a way as not to have an argument
and it became very clear during the day
that dialoguing meant we have decided
what is the right position to have you
shall not challenge this position in
other words dialoguing means how do we
get someone to move towards our position
and I've seen I checked on the internet
I see religious groups talking about
dialoguing how they can dialogue when
they're dealing with an atheist and I
firmly believe that if freedom of
expression means anything it means the
right to disagree it means the right to
state your position quite firmly quite
strongly we've had the situation here in
Canada again I think Canada is the world
leader at political correctness although
I see that that the United Kingdom is is
trying to compete with us for that honor
and at Queen's University here the
university described that decided they
would Institute sort of camera or what
they call them but people who would go
around and listen into conversations and
to make sure that people were dialoguing
proper
that there were no disagreements strong
disagreement so that people weren't
staying strong positions having to do
with issues such as race and gender in
other words thought police we have seen
this proliferation in Canada of these
Human Rights tribunals whereby if you
are a member of a group that they
consider to be protected minority group
a group that is deserving of their
sympathy and support such as gays such
as Muslims that you can literally take
anybody to a human rights tribunal and
your costs are essentially borne by the
state and the person that you have the
unlucky person you have accused has to
spend in many cases hundreds of
thousands of dollars to protect
themselves against whatever frivolous
accusation you choose to bring now it's
true that the tribunal has the right to
reject your any case that you bring this
before the tribunal but so far they tend
to reject only those cases that
challenge those protect the groups so
that we have the case for example of a
magazine that printed the 12 cartoons
that depicted Mohammed and and these are
cartoons that had been fitted all over
the world this was a news story a
magazine in Canada printed this in the
context of describing this story and
they were brought before the Human
Rights Tribunal and after three years
and you know lots of useless bureaucrats
sitting around wasting everybody's time
and money I think the case was not sure
what happened to it but at any rate the
person has got a lot of money defendants
are on the other hand when someone in
Montreal pointed out that there was an
imam spewing hatred against Jews Western
women
you know basically a lot of very nasty
stuff gaze of ours that now this person
could not be brought before the Human
Rights Tribunal because he belong to
that group of people that the this the
thought police and their associates want
to protect so I want to state
categorically and now we have the case
here in the UK where a Dutch Member of
Parliament was turned away from the UK
because he represented views that the UK
thought would cause a disruption but the
fact that there are all kinds of people
disrupting things in the UK that there
is even a lord called Lord Achmed or
somebody who regularly and you know
insights people to violence and
demonstrations is that that's okay
that's okay but an elected member of
parliament in all you don't have to
agree with what he says but surely if we
have lost the ability to discuss things
openly and to challenge things then
freedom of speech is out the window now
we have in Canada again the Human Rights
Tribunal is this lady who has a you know
earned several hundred thousand dollars
a year of the taxpayers money flies
everywhere business class stays in
expensive hotels and who is of no
benefit to society whatsoever she's now
decided to make yourself more important
that everything that's published in the
press in camera should come under review
by her committee or something such
similar committee I like arguing I have
no trouble with people to this trip
disagreement I try my best to to
persuade them of my point of view are
quite realistic I'm not going to
persuade many people of my point of view
and when I listen to them I I'm not
usually persuaded but it stimulates me
it stimulates me to think it stimulates
me to challenge some of my views if they
are adept in presenting their
perspective it definitely influences my
viewing things and I think it's healthy
to have people saying exactly what they
think i should point out that
at this meeting that I attended where we
were lectured by the student on on how
to dialogue and how not to be sort of
forceful and presenting our own views
and to be respectful of others views and
all this kind of stuff that he gets from
his so-called course at university that
when I had a chance to discuss with him
and I told him that I do not believe in
multiculturalism for a country like
Canada that I believe that people of
whatever race and origin and culture
should be welcomed into a common sense
of belonging to Canada that countries in
New World whether they be Canada the
United States Brazil wherever that
people of many different origins origins
have come together and the more
successful those societies are the less
we make a distinction based on where
people come from and people are quite
welcome to be interested in their
ancestral culture or any other culture
but I don't think it's something that we
should celebrate as a sort of defining
quality of our society and those are the
kinds of things that I said well he
immediately attacked me as being a bigot
a racist I mean he was so aggressive
here's this guy who was lecturing people
on how to dial on and when I presented
my views the way I often do here i
present them the way I think them but I
don't jump that people I don't call him
biggest a racist or anything else and he
was the exact opposite so that all these
people who are preaching dialoguing and
the sort of guardians of political
correctness they are the most intolerant
of other people's views and I see this
in particular in the academic field here
where people are afraid to speak up
people are afraid to speak up because
they will be ostracized because because
a certain group of people have decided
much like under the Catholic Church in
the Middle Ages in Europe who decided
that that the Sun revolved around the
earth and that you are not allowed to
say that that's not true and much like
in communist societies and in other
societies where a certain orthodoxy is
is established as the own
correct way to think well the political
correct group are exactly the same way
and they're totally intolerant of other
people points in other people's points
of view I have this on this English
language at ESL teachers listserv that I
belong to where they are quite
intolerant of different perspectives and
yet they somehow feel they can dialogue
their way into persuading me or they can
defang me or whatever forget it language
is great people should think people
should form their own views she's people
should be allowed to challenge whatever
whatever they choose to challenge and
even if it offends some people so what
I'm in favor of speaking up and
challenge yourself you don't agree with
what they're saying think about it and
come up with a better argument anyway
that's my little ride today and I hope
to hear back from you thank you